[Music]
russian state tv
urged putin to quote wipe the uk off the
map
holy [ __ ] nuke oh my god underwater they
got those that's pretty extreme dude so
does that mean it goes like this it goes
i think that's exactly what the
scientific cause you gotta go stay
underwater first right before it comes
out and then comes down right i thought
it just hits it from underwater oh [ __ ]
so it'll no that's just what i make up
in my mind so what they're saying is
it'll blow up underwater and it'll give
a tsunami and it will cause a over 500
foot tsunami that will
that will go all the way through to like
the highest
peak of like mountains in the uk as well
that's what sucks they don't have big
mountains like us if they only have big
but don't they know that uh london has
the highest concentration of umbrellas
that's very good point everyone else
they're just gonna everyone owns one and
they it will not even affect them that's
so true putin needs new strategists
and mary poppins well but you have to
also think because a nuclear bomb going
off in a place like that with all that
ocean yeah would cost so many sharknados
tomatoes that's the real part of my
question i was like what about all the
sea lions that's gonna spin off it's
gonna happen yeah and obviously it's
shark news and they would mutate because
it's radioactive so they would just have
legs by the end of the night to sci-fi
sci-fi channel future again i need to uh
use my science eyes because hugo sucks
at brainstorming i was like where is it
trying to attack okay we got liverpool
right there they don't even got a right
picture of
look at that you see that's ireland they
chopped it up in half dude all of
northern england and scotland is chopped
up in half is that what they're trying
to say they're going to blow up half of
uh almost all of ireland
yes because ireland's like
this big and then there's this whole
part here with like liverpool and all
that i didn't know russia and
england had beef
well this acquiring a whoopi goldberg
because they're all white anyway so
russian state tv had actually seen a
threat issued uh to the uk after
president vladimir putin's propagandist
in chief dimitri casella be off or
whatever
said the uk should be targeted with
nuclear weapons right
just out of nowhere we should target
them with nuclear weapons
that's the hip shoot idea of the day
the threat comes after boris johnson was
accused of suggesting that the uk could
use nuclear weapons against russia
without consulting nato first i thought
it all happened because boris
appeared in ukraine out of nowhere and
then like hanging out and then he
decided to send
more aid and troops to ukraine to help
and then it was the first time where
like troops were going in
something like well uh kaselyof i'm
gonna just call him kasely off from now
on claims that britain which alongside
many other countries has supplied
weapons and aid to ukraine couldn't
possibly hope to match russia in the
nuclear war so he was definitely already
aiding ukraine uh and kiselyoff said
that and what will happen after boris
johnson's words about a retaliatory
strike on russia why do they threaten
vast russia with nuclear weapons while
they are only a small island the island
is so small that one sarmat missile is
enough to drown it once and for all
that is some crazy ass statement man
damn wow yeah man i think that russia's
desperate like this war went on way too
long they're gonna get
completely [ __ ] bankrupt
like did you see that there's a graph of
like
um they're like showing how like if they
just hold out for the war for 10 days
russia would their whole economy will
get [ __ ] wait what do you mean
like um because
the sanctions and everything and on top
of that they're spending
so like
well they're they probably have a lot of
money that you can't account for because
they're all like you know there's like
underground you know what do you call it
like offshore shorts like offshore [ __ ]
all the billionaires and the government
there yeah there's probably a lot of
money that we can't like account for but
if you go based off of their like gdp
the econom the the russian economy and
things like that
this guy showed a calculation of uh like
when the ukraine war started and then
like if they can hold out for like 10
days-ish then russia's uh like money
will deplete and all this [ __ ] would
[ __ ] up i don't get that though it's
been longer than 10 days i know so it's
i guess that person was wrong
[Laughter]
so so this russian tv guy says um the
russian missile sarmat ak satan 2 the
world's most powerful is capable of
destroying an area the size of texas or
england
a single launch boris and there is no
england anymore he then added another
option to plunge britain into the depths
of the sea is the russian underwater
robotic drone poseidon it approaches the
target at a one kilometer depth with a
speed of 200 kilometers per hour
there is no way to stop this underwater
drone it has a warhead with a capacity
of up to 100 megatons that's crazy the
explosion of this thermonuclear torpedo
close to britain's shores will raise a
giant wave a tsunami up to 500 meters or
1640 feet high but why would they start
that they know that everyone's going to
blast them up to hail right after i know
they would probably just at least go
down eliminating the entire nation but
this is this is what posturing is all
about right you're trying to say like
please don't attack us because like
we'll get you real good
you know what i mean like i like the
idea of russia going we're gonna either
blow up texas or uk
you have
72 hours to come up with the dopest song
from one of these places
it's like that's a new tv show it's like
american idol global song contest
i think texas is [ __ ] if they don't
like country music oh that's true i
would definitely want to ask that first
cause that's their little thing that's
their niche what if they really like
barbecue and the country song is about
barbecue though
do you think russia likes barbecue i
don't know maybe we gotta maybe we gotta
pull from like paw wall or something you
know
you gotta get some like got any
unreleased bangers yeah we're like can
we can we bring some of that back dude
you know like the perfect time for paul
wallace come back man oh wow i love that
we need you paw wall it's all the
country the country's just on you man
paul saves texas dude back please there
is so much sensationalism going on right
now with all this stuff because this is
i mean first of all this is not new
they've had this plan for a long time
obviously we have plans to take out
every [ __ ] country on earth too it's
part of like what they do at the defense
department they can come up oh yeah
exactly
melt antarctic though
for some reason i thought you're gonna
say plan b
that's it but that's just part of you
know it's game of thrones baby yeah
right we're all trying to be a big
empire but then they're acting like
russia is is this is extra from russia
when we all do this [ __ ] to each other
which is it's part of the sensationalist
um thing about no all america is the
light
america is world police we're shining
city on the hill we're just trying to
bring democracy to the world because
everybody doesn't like democracy and
everybody deserves freedom they don't
like our freedoms no yeah we have to
fight them over there so they don't have
to fight over here i saw um putin saying
like we're gonna officially declare war
on ukraine or something and i'm like
you've been in war i'm like what's up
with all those explosions then isn't
that like the game started already i
think that [ __ ] was a military exercise
that was their liberation
oh so they're not in war yet no so they
failed at the liberation and now they
must declare that was the collateral
damage of them trying to liberate
ukraine
what what what like stories from russia
and the war do you guys even trust
because i don't even know what to think
like i hear so many different
conflicting stories constantly yeah
everyone's like oh that's actually
ukraine popular i know that's the gall's
there for sure yeah that's fire yeah
that's good i've seen that
on the russian side though right he's
settling the [ __ ] territories you
know steven
just said that the uh that ukraine kiev
pilot was also just fake the ghost of
kim we've been saying that the whole
[ __ ] time yeah i think that was just
foreign yeah they actually finally
admitted it yeah that like got all
strapped up to go oh yeah
they even say like uh the president
what's his name um zielinski when he's
doing all these meetings with
politicians they're saying that's all
staged it's a photo and i'm like what do
you mean stage like
it's like they have a set they're at
universal studios and they're like in
different you know or because those
buildings it's a photo opportunity like
we're like so zelinski's wearing like
these fatigues and like it looks like
he's out there like fighting a war and
like like has a collision of coffin [ __ ]
and then nancy pelosi's in the pants
who's just going like this and they're
they're all some people are saying nancy
pelosi um what's his name um borrister
all of these leaders aren't actually in
ukraine they're saying like they're
somewhere else she's fighting the front
lines bro
she got a helmet on and she's out there
it wouldn't make more sense that's her
style for if it was going to happen
anyway it would make more sense for
zielinski to leave ukraine and take
these photos with different people in
romania it's like sending other world
leaders to the hot zones you know right
right and it is even zelinski a good
shot we don't know what his like [ __ ]
like military background is we know his
cod score is pretty good though yeah kd
is really good sick it's like he's
killed him i heard his dance scores
really good too because he did dancing
with the stars
he didn't win though he didn't win no
but he's good
it's hard to tell right because which
one is ukrainian propaganda to scare
russians which one's russian propaganda
which one's american propaganda like
keep track of it
remember when um the first iraq war was
going down like with with bush senior
and there was this little girl who went
to the u.n and she was telling everybody
about how iraqis were taking babies and
putting them into incubators to kill
them
and it turned out to be a totally
[ __ ] story that nobody even checked
out but our media parroted it everywhere
to say like we need this war we gotta
[ __ ] iraqis aren't even people
they're killing babies incubators we're
doing it right now with russia if you
watch our media they're dehumanizing the
[ __ ] out of of russian citizens saying
that they're all like down
for for killing all like slot uh
slaughtering
ukrainians killing like babies and all
this listen with every yeah and they'll
say that like there's a mom who's found
with a little a mind attached to her
child and she was dead and and the
russians put the mind between her and
her child so that when a soldier pulled
her away it would blow them up blow them
both up [ __ ] like that that just makes
so so it makes our um
us citizenry fine with
indiscriminately killing russians but i
think with them uh with now i think it's
pretty sick how we can see what's really
happening in ukraine there's people
vlogging in ukraine there's people
vlogging in [ __ ] russia
and then you can see the world kind of
come together and be like man this
warship's [ __ ] crazy why are we doing
this this is stupid and then you try to
get your world leaders to be more
accountable for their game of thrones
and just be like quit [ __ ] doing that
[ __ ] quit killing peasants
and for your [ __ ] gain you know you
know what i think is kind of a nice
correction that is also kind of sad is
it also shows the futility of social
media
like nothing that you hashtag is gonna
[ __ ] stop this war yeah oh say that
don't say that how many people with
ukrainian flags on their twitter account
do you still see they [ __ ] left that
[ __ ] but i think like war kind of does
show you the reality like we went way
too long thinking all these like
self-servicing things are effective but
like when real war happens it's like you
have to have you have to be fighting it
with real war it's funny you say that
because i haven't seen you post one
gofundme for ukraine
one thing he didn't um he wasn't
funding um that but he was retweeting
all those yeah oh my god awareness i was
only looking at your ig i didn't look at
your twitter i'm on the anti sign i go
to no fund me
and he just takes money
dude i didn't see any photo yeah i
didn't see any photo with a hashtag
stand with ukraine so yeah i see we know
yellow or blue we all did it but not you
because i stand with you i mean it's an
inside job all of it
apparently there's a beer that is named
putin as a [ __ ] and that's on sale
in the u.s now to raise money for
ukraine well that'll stop the war
man
there's a pretty cool um
[ __ ] i forgot his name but he has a
video
on youtube
breaking down all the people who
profited from afghanistan
and uh or the iraqi war and uh pretty
much all the uh all the conflicts that
green wall
no it's a it's the same guy
mr beast that was on um i think his name
is john something
um he basically did one about how uh
liberal policies are destroying major
cities
um and it was it was on um washington
post or something like that so
but he's yeah he's like a youtuber but
he's a sick ass journalist like he's
doing some really good homework you know
yeah
[Music]